if you're intelligent and you live
past 40 you will outgrow your culture i
mean some people may do it
sooner but you have to be a complete
idiot
to just buy in at 55
at 60 at 75 at 80 you know what are you
still going to be doing
uh expressing homophobic views voting
republican
and worrying about the a b and c's of
the
phony reality i mean most people get to
a place where they just
see it's a bunch of crap you know
the the scandals are recycled the
philosophical issues are recycled the
technical innovations are recycled
once you've been through about three
cycles of this
you realize that you know this is a
media created
uh state of cultural involvement
and reciprocal narcissism
only to be assuaged by the expenditure
of money
and that you can just walk away from
it's
uh it's unnecessary and in fact this
walking away from it by more and more
people
i think is a precondition to any kind of
reasonable attempt to get the planet
on a course where crises begin to
diminish
rather than be endlessly exacerbated
the the values of production
acquisition reproduction
are all uh faithful to any human
enterprise except the short-term success
of the marketplace
and apparently that is to be the primary
maximized value
so this is a long answer to the question
the short answer is uh
my approach to reality is
uh hands-on
and i wouldn't call it scientific
because it's not statistical
but it's realistic
first of all nothing is what it appears
to be
but on the other hand uh very large
structures are not
likely to come into being unless they
quickly achieve their purpose
so in other words forms of conspiracy
theory seem to me
over baroque i think the real truth
about how reality works
is that it's pretty much on automatic
chaos
is the ruling player chance
is cast in the number two role
and the unexpected is in there somewhere
and then you know somebody can organize
a conspiracy and keep it running in one
direction in the face of all that
well uh fine um
it's good to talk about this here
because esselm has been
you know a place where many very deep
new ideas
have been generated revolutions in
psychotherapy
revolutions in general systems thinking
very significant political movements
have been advanced from here
uh the whole soviet
re-assessment and all that but also
echelon has been a source of some of the
wackiest
and least anchored of
of these ideas and and
that's fine in the context of the idea
that all forms of advocacy
should be permitted and i would agree
with that
but i think the the counter or the
reflexive value that must attend that is
that all
forms of advocacy must be fairly
criticized and there needs to be a
general
and this is the part that
is the itch i keep trying to scratch
there needs to be a general
understanding of what constitutes
of what we mean by words like proof
evidence uh
and testimony
the you know the law isn't interesting
it's interesting to me how the law has
been remarkably immune
to the general woolliness that has crept
into thinking uh
it is if you commit murder that the
grace made you do it
is not defensible the devil made me do
it i mean maybe it is defensible but
it's a pitiful defense
people it may be traumatic for people to
testify
in front of a grand jury but on the
other hand if you are
have some evidentiary material related
to a crime
you're going to have to
talk to the grand jury in the name of
the generally established canons of
what is good for society and i think
you know if the meth if those kinds of
methods were applied to a lot of
so-called paranormal phenomena
abductions flying saucer signings so
forth and so on
they would just melt like the morning do
it's the uh it's the inability
to subpoena testimony and explore
contradiction
that makes this stuff at the second
third fourth and fifth
retelling seems so compelling
and then one other aspect of all this
and then we can go on to something else
and that is we seem to be very naive
about the nature of communication
and how 95
or 99 of what moves around
is unsubstantiated rumor based on
uninformed
opinion i mean
you know we sit here with the assumption
that we're all in the same universe
more or less and that we're all
experiencing the same reality more or
less
but this is just a polite fiction i mean
if
if we were to go around the circle and
instead of
telling your name and your professional
occupation
you were uh asked to
explain how a common household device
works so for you the television set
for you the osterizer for you the
thermostat
for you the furnace i think we would
largely discover that if anything past
the most trivial
level it just turns into elves and
goblins
out there i mean we're hardly different
from new guinea highlanders
uh and we caught we think we understand
everybody's
model works for them even if they think
you know that it's hema goblins in your
blood
that run around carrying oxygen because
they heard it that way
in second grade so
this is sort of a terrifying thought to
contemplate
that the actual understanding of reality
is held
in our species as a kind of diffuse
cloud of expertise but when you try to
tease it out from any given individual
in the cloud
you find just just a cartoon
is what you actually find you know if
you read ulysses
james joyce's masterpiece a lot of
what's going on in
in leopold bloom's head as he wanders
around dublin are crack-brained
understandings of technical devices how
he thinks the electric tram works
how he thinks about the odds in the
horse race
how he thinks about how the sewer works
and it's all
uh absolutely cartoon like fairy tales
about reality well if we don't
understand things as simple as can
openers and tv sets
then what is our real grip on phenomena
like
representative democracy or the
healthcare
delivery system or the theory of
evolution
and molecular genetics you know it
begins to get
pretty um pretty scary
out there so all of these things taken
in stride um
lead me back to the conclusion that the
way to investigate reality
is carefully with intellectual
consistency
seek the weird seek the bizarre
seek the edge but understand
that
you can only rely directly on
your own experience the conclusions you
draw
from it and mathematics
and anything which comes down the
collective epigenetic telegraph
is so shaped by the cultural mind
that it none of it can be trusted all of
it
serves hidden agendas of salesmanship
marketing propagandization uh
glamorization fetishization
in other words nothing can be taken at
face value nothing is
what it seems and if you move through
reality like that
testing as you go uh
i think you know there's not a great
deal of danger of going over the edge
in my own experience of doing that the
only interesting thing i found
that transcended the mundane was
psychedelics
but i'm perfectly willing to admit that
one life
may not be enough and maybe if i'd gone
to paraguay
instead of nepal or maybe you know i
would have found
something but i do believe induction
induction if not prosecuted
too far can be helpful
what do i mean by induction if you meet
20 bankers and they all are
jerks you may be reasonable informing
the supposition that the 21st banker
will be a jerk you may be wrong
but the force of presupposition uh
is with you so uh induction
deduction and experiential
confirmation what's not a good thing i
think is
buying in on hype or charisma
the real is real it's real
it does not require your participation
to be real
on the other hand a mirage an illusion a
delusion
your fifty percent of of its life
blood without you it can't function
without your credulity your need your
hope your weakness your inability to
ontologically
parse what's going on it's almost like
there are two
ways of looking at the world and they
have and they come
down to whether you think the world is
out there and was there before you
got here and will be there after you
depart
and this is essentially the view of
science you know
or if your uh the other philosophical
flavor has different names but it's
usually called radical idealism or
something like that
and it's the idea that we are making
the world moment to moment somehow it
depends
on our existence and of course
immediately following that assumption is
the idea that
it we can change it with our minds
which brings up the moral dilemma then
why is it so
resistant or why isn't it the way we
want it to be if it's so malleable why
is it so
uh resistant and
once you understand you know what
philosophy
is i think you you see that these two
positions
are polar and that
there's a lot to recommend each one and
it's very hard to make a fusion
i tend to act as though the world
is really there but i think
that ideology is very poisonous
and that we should not we should not
believe anything it's a it's a form of
metaphysical hubris
it means you really think you're an
important
cosmic actor i mean if you met a termite
who wanted to tell you his beliefs
you would be puzzled why he even
bothered
well are you so greatly different than
this termite in relationship to the
cosmic all
of it so beliefs are like
there are forms of culturally endowed
paralysis you know i believe in the
democratic individual
i believe in the resurrection and the
life well so what
we don't care what we want to know is
what can we
reach through examining the evidence and
applying inductive and deductive
uh approaches to it i i
you know we've talked about this before
but some people think
that what life is about is looking for
the good ideologies
we want good ideologies not bad
ideologies
but i think the history of the 20th
century is trying to
show us is shouting to us in fact
that all ideology that it the ideology
itself
is a betrayal of being
uh you know certainly fascism
when carried to its logical extremes
seemed
quite unappealing the holocaust
and so forth how then is it
that the countervailing idea which
people of
moral morally felt obligation
were moved toward produced nearly equal
if not
equal horror you know socialism
you know you didn't i mean different
people died for different reasons
but you have the same thing camps secret
police
the knock on the door the uh god-like
bureaucrat the indomitable state on
and on and on so it looks to me like
ideology is one of these
neonatal behaviors that culture
downloads
on us in other words belief is for kids
it's a fairy tale marxism is no
different than a belief in the easter
bunny
uh probability theory is no different
than a belief in the easter bunny
everybody needs to get a grip
on the uncertainty of the intellectual
enterprise
[Music]
you